a lot of interesting things from the
combine last night uh rich was front and
center with his buddy daniel jeremiah he
joins us now from indianapolis to tell
us all about it welcome to your show
rich how are we doing
how are you guys today welcome to you
what up rich how are you we're good
we're good um
i i was doing my radio gig last night uh
critiquing the quarterbacks and
everything so i had it on mute but a
friend of mine andrew perloff said you
gave me a little shout out there about
uh about my like for carson strong yeah
yeah man thank you uh yeah of course and
and
boy he's
he's
his last name is appropriate yeah that's
that's a good point
he can bring it man
he can throw it he can throw like nobody
else's business um what was your biggest
takeaway we have a lot of you know
things to talk about with you from the
combat but what was your biggest
takeaway covering it from from beginning
to end with the with the wide outs and
quarterbacks last night well i i think
um
yet another
draft where
the wide receiver position will um
just keep stocking up teams with one
after another after another
of of kids that can really
really really change the game i mean the
last two years
you've seen a rookie receiver from lsu
come in and transform
an offense that that he joins and
it you know i
you'd be hard-pressed to sit here and
say that somebody that we saw last night
won't won't do the same i mean they're
all really really good and they they
caught the ball well they ran
very well um
man olave and garrett wilson in um
seeing them with my own two eyes
um really um
was amazing i i i thought the the wide
receiver position has stopped and i'm
not surprised now to be very honest with
you i i don't know if you can connect
dots but you see
like say somebody a veteran like cole
beasley suddenly might not be back with
the bills like that's a
headline that just popped in the last
half hour i mean if you
you want to go ahead and draft the kid
in the fourth or fifth round i think he
can actually start for your team that's
what i saw last night and then the
quarterback spot i mean malik willis had
me hello um he's got a big arm he's got
some big game
and um as i tweeted out last night even
during the broadcast if i'm a steelers
fan i'm like yes please
the response i got from steve smith on
the turf and then of course through some
other people on twitter was like
how do you know he's going to be there
at 20. i mean i think he's going to get
pushed up and he might even be the first
guy off the board yeah there's a lot of
hype that comes into us and i always
knew this was going to be the case right
any time between when the super bowl
ends to when the combine happens and
then ultimately the draft
the spin the hype train all of it plays
into the quarterback's advantage and
ultimately there's going to be general
managers out there that fear
they're going to miss out on the next
great quarterback and they'll do and
move heaven and earth to go get that
yeah and and you know he's got he's got
a lot of the it factor i knew i know
you know the fact that he played at
liberty means not many people saw him
play but he was at auburn he was an
auburn
um
kid he was an auburn kid for a couple
years and when auburn went to beau nix
after stidham left um that's when he
transferred
and he's got big game men i saw him i
thought desmond ritter had a nice night
last night but again you're just sitting
there and
in um
in workout clothes and there's really no
adversity other than the fact
that you've been poked and prodded for
three and a half days beforehand and
then you have to get out on the field
it's just not a really
you know and that's why people love
their pro days a little bit better
um that you don't go through the
gauntlet of the medical and the
um
and the psychological the interviews i
mean it really is i mean this is just
the end of the combine they're done
and there's a relief when you're done
with it but it's the most important part
of it because it is the physical
you know
attributes that got many of these kids
to the invitation of the combine
so outside of all that like you just
don't know it's just part of a puzzle
the piece of puzzle you that all the
time
but um
uh this draft tonight i think you're
gonna see
maybe the first overall pick out there
with one of the offensive linemen like
that's that's the way it's going to go
and i know that
last year there were only
three quarterbacks taken in the first
three picks
uh we we may not see one in the top 10
this year
um offensive lineman defensive lineman
and maybe one of the ohio state wide
receivers which whichever one you like
speaking of those wide receivers right
chris salave uh ran a 429 unofficial and
then we saw tae kwon thornton at the
wide receiver position run the 4-2-1
that looked like it broke the record
what was your impression there when that
happens because brockman and i were
talking about this right the the fact
they go and run it and it's a drop the
mic moment like i just broke the record
fasts out there i know it's i know they
say unofficial but whatever i'm not
going to run a second time second time
and then an hour later comes back that
it was seven seven one hundredths of a
second off
oh lava rana wound up running a 439 and
we didn't get those times until dj and i
daniel jeremiah were walking back to the
hotel yeah and we stayed on a half an
hour after the
the on-field drills were done and we're
like if olabe had known that do you
think he would have just rested and on
his laurels and what do you think he
would maybe run it again
and you know um the answer is maybe but
i don't think it's any it
again um the difference between him
running a 4-2-8 and a 4-3-9
with the clear
eye in the sky
tape
right on him i i honestly don't think it
makes a difference as to whether
somebody's going to draft him in this
spot or that spot i mean the 439 just
shows he's fast and he's fast he's
capable he's incredible
now it's for somebody like you know the
kid from baylor who we saw 4-2-1 and
look we i don't know what happened last
night to be honest with you because
we we had a simulcam all set up
for uh olave and terry mclaren who ran a
435
and um you know and we saw in the
simulcam that mclaren beat olave and
we're like okay so that's why we say
these times are unofficial right you
know like when we say it we mean it now
the yellow line during an nfl game
it's pretty official but i mean um these
times are truly unofficial where they're
started with a hand time and then you
know somebody it's a button
once the kid is off and running and it's
supposed to match up with the electronic
time that's
on first movement it's supposed to go
and then you know uh we have a hand
timer in case the that electronic goes
down then we'd use that
but the electronic was off last night
there's no question about it and
hopefully they'll get it fixed for
tonight yeah well we better hope that
the electronics are off for you maybe we
can get it under 605 when you run it
here in about a month well i mean we're
always saying that you know again my
plan is to run it in a few weeks um in
los angeles just like i did last year
and everyone was like you should get out
there because it it looked a fast track
like it was a fast track last night yeah
fast track you know wait look but
yeah one of the one of the cooler things
of the night uh i saw and it looked like
you enjoyed you had giovanni uh in the
uh booth with you and dj
talk us talk to us a little bit about
that and and how much fun you had with
that experience well he's a sweet kid
from philly who's now moved to
indianapolis because um
you know uh his dad got a job out here
and it interesting enough happened just
as his favorite eagle carson wentz came
out here too and
so he had tickets to the combine i saw
it on twitter and
and you know as soon as he tweeted out
hey i'm going to the combine
you know the nfl network did
due diligence and got him in the booth
and it was pretty cool uh he's a sweet
kid i've been on his show
and
you know even though he lives out here
in the midwest he still has his philly
roots when i asked him you know hey
howie roseman might be listening to you
right now what would your message be to
him and he's like well howie draft this
wide receivers and for the love of god
get us linebackers it's what he said for
the love of god
you know and it was fantastic
and he did meet roseman and siriani
later and then he went out
after he was done in the booth he went
and hung out on the digital um
broadcast with colleen wolfe who as you
know is
silly through and through so it was
really sweet and you know there's so
much crap and awfulness going on in our
world
that to see a kid who loves the game
and and loves talking about the game
just being here and then hanging out
with us you know to make that happen
that's what it's all about so
that was pretty cool a great chance to
meet him
he does love the game he does know the
game he's that's why people dig him yeah
because they just they they feel his
warmth and his essence and i'm glad he
was on the network last night well it
was really fun to see and and i and just
from somebody was viewing it you just
the the expression on both yours and
dj's faces made it i mean that even
makes it you just were enjoying yourself
so much and that that's really
meaningful uh to see that coming from
you
it's beautiful
um did you see um the music that i was
telling you about did you hear the music
i was telling you about in the first
part i know you said you the sound was
down but yeah
oh yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah the music the music um got shut
down as i said during the broadcast last
night i asked daniel jeremiah what was
it what was a shorter tenure
in the history of the nfl the music at
the combine or bill belichick is the
head coach of the jets
that's what i asked him on the air last
night what was the music what was the
reason the music started playing you
could just see the scouts in the stands
kind of look at each other
like who who left the radio on you know
like what's going on i don't know if
they got that much of a heads up there
were 10 000 fans there last night so i
guess that they were trying to create an
atmosphere for the brands
and and so they started playing music
but the problem is the music was kind of
you know
it was intrusive in the fact that
for instance uh that they announced they
announced on on a on a loud speaker
who's running who's not who's running
because it they have a medical issue and
who's not running because they just
don't wanna
and that they'll run at the pro day and
those announcements are made certainly
the more important announcements being
you know uh who's running a second time
so like for instance when olave doesn't
run a second time they announce like you
know chris olave um
essentially isn't elects to you know not
run again right
or or you know malik willis is not
running you know he'll run at its pro
day like they literally make those
announcements
and scouts and gm's couldn't see the
announcements couldn't hear those things
there's music
some messages that were kind of sent up
the chain of command
and all of a sudden
it was quiet as a church in there i got
to push back on this i know you were
texting us about it and i i kind of you
know said it was whack but like
these scouts
it's not for them okay it's it's a it's
a television event for fans
and it's turning into this big type of
tentpole off season event but as we head
into the draft right the evaluation
period okay we can set up some kind of
tech service for the scouts if they
really want to know if a guy isn't going
to run a second time like someone with
the nfl can get everyone's uh phone
numbers on a file and hit one big group
text and chris salave will not be
running a second grade everyone's got
the phone
keep the music on if you're going to
have 10 000 fans there and make this
into this big
thing like the scouts have to take a
back seat i'm sorry yeah but that's
that's not what this thing is this is no
it is what it is what it is now for the
scouts chris this is literally what are
the pro days for
like
one of the other one of the other the
pro days are for initially for uh other
scouts that
are in the area or kids that were not
invited to the combine like not every
kid if there's only 325
invites to this day if i'm a player if
i'm if i'm the players next year i'm
saying i'm not i'm not i'm not going to
the comment unless music's rocking
that's that's the deal now you know what
i don't know if that's the hill they
want to die
but like like for instance georgia has
the most kids here but not all their
kids here
you know yeah and then and then there
might be some
small schools around georgia around
athens that might send some kids there
so it's just another way pro days are
just another way
look the combine is essentially the
reason why it exists and the reason why
it will always exist is for the medical
examinations right and for some of the
face-to-face interviews
exactly while we're at it
and while we're at it doing all of these
on-field drills while everybody's there
that's the reason why it was created so
now the fact that tfl is coming in with
some fans
and trying to make it a fan experience
it still shouldn't it still doesn't
intrude on what this is all about which
is the on-field drills and the medical
evaluations and the nfl network itself
has been making
you know a dance around that for
17 18 years
so you can't ask everyone else to adapt
and then the scouts just to go go about
business as usual like they have been
for the last 30 years like they have to
adapt as well and if it means like
putting in some
you know some buds to say you don't have
to hear the musics and so be it
well it's kind of like chris like let's
just put it this way
you know let's just say you've done
something a certain way for a very long
time and you're trying to broaden things
out
uh for others or people who are
coming in to try and broaden it out for
others let's say you're you're a burger
draft right you want to get more people
at your burger draft and you're going to
allow a couple of people to eat whatever
they want because other than that
you know other than that then they won't
attack right let's just say you're
trying to expand
your
your your audience for it right you'll
still be saying screw that
right do that you come here you gotta be
only what burger is drafted
for you
right wouldn't you say that after all
that time
but if i want to play music you want to
have a conversation you just like talk
over the music
the scouts are you for your burger dress
you get it
and they're like turn the music off
you don't even use it while they don't
have a tech system set up i will say
this though the fans were fun
in the fact that any when david bell by
the way we nailed the glue guys no we
nailed them
they were like four four gorilla glue
guys last night alone
and um
and so when david bell purdue he went to
high school 12 miles down the road when
he did anything like it was loud yeah
fans were cheering they were like clowns
have never heard before david bell goes
through the gauntlet drill he's done
with it huge standing ovation
that's awesome so weird now scouts
should get used to that because it's
just applause
you know what i mean like that's that's
one thing and all like any time there
were like 10 dudes drunk dudes like
probably from like columbus
anytime olave and garrett wilson did
anything and this was late at night when
half the crowd was gone they were going
ape anytime they did anything
and dot in the eye in the stands
yeah and then when they were doing the
the go routes the quarterbacks and your
guys strong from nevada malik willis and
whoever could really crank it
and throw it downfield 60 yards in the
air
and then they completed it everybody
went crazy and that was fun like there
was actually energy in the building for
that
and i hope you know scouts or whomever
don't have a problem with that
plus the music sucked i don't know who
chose it really wasn't good it's kind of
like sucking it's like stuck in the
largest elevator ever
i think just all around it was uh
clearly clearly the players didn't
choose the music here's the move next
year next year when the quarterbacks are
throwing let the quarterback who's
throwing have control of the playlist
just kind of like the walk-out music
individualized playlist for the workouts
oh gosh i think i don't i don't know if
everyone was on the same page going in
yeah but i'll tell you what they
certainly ripped that page out of the
book in a hurry
in a hurry hey uh
i wanna i wanna i wanna talk into one
thing outside the combine but first i i
want to speak to the you know the kenny
picket news it was just a punch line all
day long right eight and a half inch
hands these tiny hands how can he even
function as a player all these things
right and then nfl network right
right there cameraman right next to him
he's not he's not oblivious to the guy
you know filming his hands and not his
body or his face it's looking right at
his hands and then he goes out and i
thought performed as good as anybody
last night he was compact he was
accurate he was fluid in everything he
did talk to about us talk to us a little
bit about that and how do you think his
performance came out after all the
scrutiny of the hands that something he
can't control
oh yeah i mean he's he's gonna he'll be
a first round quarterback no doubt i
mean
there's no question that he'll go in the
first round
um
dj daniel said that you know there will
be some teams that will literally take
him off their boards because he's only
got eight and a half inch hands and
i i can't imagine that would be such a
problem i mean the guy wears gloves for
a reason i think he gets a nice grip on
it kurt warner was on the field he was
mister wearing gloves and domes his
entire career better grip i mean
i don't know kid ran kid rams sub 47.
i mean he's really athletic and he's
tall and he's good
and he's done it in pittsburgh so
you know as i said on the show yesterday
desmond ritter's got 10 plus inch hands
and fumbled it over 30 times in
cincinnati so
i i i don't know you tell me
i thought i thought he was back yeah i
just thought he was great last night
good yeah he looked good there's no
question about that all right um one
thing outside the combine uh purview uh
the conversation and adam schefter
reporting that uh amari cooper there in
dallas um may be released before the
league year starts your your thoughts on
that and uh uh and what that
accomplishes for the dallas cowboys
well i mean look when when they signed
cooper and and zeke and knowing that dak
was going to get his money and then he
did i mean
how many teams can have a quarterback
running back wide receiver combination
count for what like 70 million on on
your cap i mean no matter how large your
your the cap number keeps going up by
whatever margin i mean at some point
that's just not sustainable
and the fact that zeke's still around is
kind of amazing because you think the
running back would be the one with the
quickest expiration date
but it was obvious that amari cooper was
no longer you know the number one target
in the offense last year that it was cd
lam
100
you know the fact that amari cooper
would essentially have to speak up which
she never does
um and um
you know to say hey i'm still here
definitely was odd
to say the least and again i just saw
all those kids last night at the wide
receiver position i mean why would you
yeah you know
terrific and he's still very young
you're talking about a 20 million dollar
hit of some sort
um or close to it i'd imagine i think it
was what 100 million dollar contract you
sign again i don't know what phony money
was in it or what it would count for
this year or i think it's 16 million i
think it's 16 million they save a huge
chunk of change it's a huge chunk of
change you know that gallup is hurt and
um but that doesn't surprise me it just
doesn't and then the fact that he was
one of their their few unvaccinated
players still on the team last year i
think really wrangled
um the joneses and it's interesting
again the covert protocols yesterday
were were shelved
but still what will linger is somebody
at a time when all they had to do was
take a shot
and that would give them a better chance
to win and they did not
um is something that i think will linger
in the mind's eye of of uh front offices
and ownership and i think you put it all
together and that's one of the reasons
why
cooper will be on another team
and you know obviously there will be
some teams that will jump all over him
certainly when you got to start from
scratch on his contract um but it didn't
really surprise me to hear that today we
did it most likely with uh with chris
brockman today and he he
prefaced one of these for for our friend
here tj jefferson is it most likely that
the dallas cowboys playing the super
bowl or that rich who plays in the super
bowl first cowboys or amari cooper
oh that's a good one how is that how
how'd you enter well of course tj was
was the dallas cowboys but us in the
real world said amari cooper because
he'll probably end up with the chiefs or
the rams or the patriots or something
like that
did you imagine him on the chiefs i mean
he always that's what i said that's the
game for the raiders against the chiefs
he had a couple of a couple of 200 yard
games against them uh yeah uh uh so i'll
take what's more likely cooper elsewhere
rather than dallas um without him
all right rich
as always thanks so much for taking time
out to help us out appreciate you for
the trust again with uh with your
platform it's been amazing three days so
you enjoy your rest of the trip and
we'll see you soon
you got it i'm at four eastern today
tomorrow and then um two eastern on
sunday and then back in that chair on
monday all right everybody
thank you guys rich eisen from the rich
eisen show
joining us from indianapolis
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here